and I didn't get any work for about six
months and I thought it's always work at
the post in the downtime while you're
waiting for a decision
you're not just twiddling your thumbs
you're not just sitting on the couch
you're not watching Netflix you're off
hustling new business for every problem
the problem itself presents an
opportunity that dwarfs the problem rise
and shine it's expresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's start your day off right together
grab your cup of coffee and sip on
today's message seize your opportunities
over to you Denzel Washington I had a
real momentum going from college I want
through all these roles and plays that I
just mentioned right up until doing
Carbon Copy in 1980-81 and I didn't get
any work for about six months and I
thought as always work at the post ology
I better go back down at his City
Council meeting and but I got a small
play a one-act play about two guys when
I named Malcolm and the other named
Elijah I was even saying Elijah when I
first met I'm looking at yeah yeah good
big big big big role and that really
jump started my career again because the
play went over very well we did it down
at the new federal theater Henry Street
Settlement and that led I went right
from that plate to a soldier's play off
Broadway and right from a soldier's
plate to st. elsewhere you need to
hustle while you wait if you can embody
this advice and apply it to your
business on a day to day basis
this will be the biggest momentum shift
in your company this will move you so
close to your goals at an incredible
pace that is unbelievable just most
people don't do it
hustle while you wait listen with every
goal that you have it relies on other
people you need other people to be a
part of your process right if you're
selling to customers you need the
customer to say yes they have to make
the decision there's a bunch of back and
forth if you're waiting on a product to
come you're waiting on your supplier to
come forward this there's always things
that are outside your control that
you're waiting other people for and yes
when it comes to you you want to get it
done as soon as possible
if a customer is asking for a quote you
want to get it off your plate ASAP you
should not be the bottleneck in momentum
happening in your business that's a
whole other problem as soon as something
comes to you it's getting taken care of
and you're building momentum but you're
still even at the most peak efficiency
waiting for other people to take action
that's gonna happen so what do you do in
those moments you hustle you build new
momentum you build new clients you build
new relationships you maintain the
existing ones and get everything done as
soon as possible and then in the
downtime while you're waiting for a
decision
you're not just twiddling your thumbs
you're not just sitting on the couch
you're not watching Netflix you're off
hustling new business quick example I
was doing a photo shoot with Richard
this guy's a celebrity photographer he's
done lady gaga done the whole bunch of
rappers he came over and we did a photo
shoot together and in between his shots
he's gonna set up lights he's got to get
his fog machine going he's got to get
the right angle he's got to set up the
green-screen and so when he needs me I'm
there I'm ready I'm posing I'm in action
I'm ready to go but there's a lot of
setup in between shots and so what am i
doing I'm pulling up my phone and I'm
responding to you guys I'm making videos
I'm doing responses I'm getting on
Twitter and Instagram I'm doing on
snapchat I'm sending out video responses
to you guys I'm working I'm hustling on
my downtime
Lewton for rich for this project I am
hustling connecting with you guys and
that's the approach that you need to
take people say well how do I find the
time to respond to people on social
media I probably have a way bigger cats
and you guys do and I find the time
because I make the time in between the
other things that I'm doing this is so
critical people are losing so much time
the answer is not to wake up two hours
early or think that's gonna solve your
problem the answer is you're losing time
every single day you are leaking
valuable time from your daily schedule
and so I highly highly highly encourage
you to take this message home while you
are working while people are waiting on
you for stuff you are doing your best
and deliver as soon as possible so that
you are not the bottleneck in your
business but then while you're awaiting
other people you get your hustle on you
continue to build momentum it is such a
hack to get you closer to achieving the
goals that you have for yourself stop
sleeping while you're waiting for other
people to get back to you hustle while
you wait
I've got some really special bonus clips
for you but before that question of the
day I want to know what are you gonna do
today the hustle while you wait what is
one thing you were going to do today to
hustle while you wait leave me down the
comments below
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
and enjoy the bonus clips
[Music]
I grew up watching movies and imagining
myself on screen so aside from the very
serious things that I do I will
occasionally do a snakes on a plane
because those are the kind of movies I
like when I was a kid I always wanted to
see myself in a movie with a bunch of
snakes and I'm I'm still trying to find
the right you know slasher movie to do
because I like slasher movies and I'm
still you know I did things like deep
blue sea because I wanted to run from
something that had big teeth and Harlan
Iceland so I'm not that serious about it
you know I I really think movies should
be fun and I think they should be
entertaining if I want to teach you
something I'll do a documentary but I do
this because it feeds me it feeds my
artistic sense a lot of people think I
do too many movies I read an article in
paper yesterday about me doing too many
movies but I mean you know writers get
up and write every day
painters get up and paint every day
actors only have so many acting
opportunities in a lifetime
I'm gonna take mine as they come and do
as many movies as I can before him about
of here being an actor or even being an
artist and I had studied in school
behind the camera was not even in the
vernacular of my dreams
I was raised 9 to 5 you go to work your
work you work your way up a scale that's
from your old man right yeah and that
was all I was able to even like I said
dream about so the idea of living life
and having a career that was in the arts
that was in the storytelling business it
was something that's really fun it was
not something that like I said I even
dreamed up I was in the right place
right time right bar guy found me and
said you want to come in and read for a
part in a movie I'm here producing
called Dazed and Confused I said sure I
got a read for the part it's got three
lines three lines turns in three weeks
work there pay me three hundred
twenty-five bucks a day people were
telling me I'm pretty good at it and I
think I'm getting away with something
and I still do feel like I'm getting
away with something for every problem
the problem itself presents an
opportunity that Dwarfs the problem and
that is to say that if I had only looked
at my failure with the audio book and
viewed it as a failure in the product
let's say and not in the
process I wouldn't have taken away much
instead I realized that my approach
wasn't right fixed my a person that has
led to a lot of great successes raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion and not one drop of myself
work depends on your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details